citizens of reject nation welcome to
another episode of koi's comic corner i
am so excited to have you with me today
now today we're going to be talking
about the guardians of the galaxy 3
trailer i was in that room i was in hall
h and it was incredibly powerful but
we're going to talk about the trailer
we're gonna talk about my thoughts and
theories on that trailer and what it
implies for how i think the movie's
gonna round out and solve some mysteries
i think a lot of people didn't realize
how big of mysteries they were now i'm
gonna focus on very important things
like high evolutionary gamora rocket
raccoon not necessarily a play-by-play
of the trailer itself because there's
tons of those videos already and i'm
coming from a comic book background not
just a theory background i'm gonna give
you comic informed theories as best i
can please leave a like those help us
very much please comment that's how i
know what you folks want to see more of
please also subscribe and hit that bell
so you can know when i make more koi
comic corners and thank you to everyone
who has been following me on tik tok
those responses have been amazing and i
appreciate it that's where i do my short
form content to parallel this long form
stuff for you all right let's get into
it
now i want to focus on the important
things in this trailer like i said but i
also want to focus on how that room felt
so this room was way sadder than i
expected there is a revelry to hall h
there is an inherent cheering and and
exuberance in all age that was there
don't get me wrong james gunn coming on
stage was incredible the cheers for the
cast walking on stage that was all a lot
but there was a somberness once everyone
was on stage there was a beautiful
bittersweet melancholy that i wasn't
expecting everyone was crying on that
stage i think this movie breaks us the
entire cast watched that trailer
backstage for the first time and then
came out weeping there was a lot of
emotion on that stage and it's something
that i felt in the entire marvel hall h
panel i mean obviously the wakanda
forever trailer you saw it and probably
cried at home imagine being around 6 000
people that were also experiencing this
art as well as the cast who made this
art that knows what that represents and
what's to come so the entire hall h was
very heavy very melancholic and
especially this and the wakanda forever
trailer and i think that does spell
certain doom for a lot of members of
this cast things go poorly for the
guardians of the galaxy especially for
rocket raccoon now this kicks off with
do you realize by the flaming lips which
is a very somber remix of this song and
that really matches if if james gunn's
gonna do a song it's it's important the
man is the master of the needle drop
james gunn and edgar wright have the
best manipulation of emotion with pop
music of anyone working right now they
know what they're doing and this version
of the flaming lips broke us immediately
it is it is somber it talks about death
it really
kind of marinades into you with sadness
now there's literally a line in this
song that says do you realize that
everyone you know will someday die i
think that's going to be the guardians
of the galaxy james gunn did come out on
stage saying just because a story is
reaching a 10 doesn't mean everyone is
going to die but i think that is either
maybe true but also that's been the
rumor for a while he's gonna have to
mislead us in some way i don't know if
it's gonna be literally seven for seven
guardians bite it but i do think the
death toll on this film is going to be
substantial and i do think it does
weren't bringing up again that he said
this is the last time we will see this
iteration of the guardians of the galaxy
in addition to the somber tone there
were moments of levity um
specifically we did have a moment where
karen gillan said that her character
does have some levity now that her dad
thanos has passed away and another
important sequence i think is there's a
moment where quill sees the ravagers in
their new installment and it looks like
we do get the guardians two ravagers
that we met i think stallone come back
and michael rose's mom comes back i
think those characters are here which is
exciting but we see those ravagers and
there's a moment of tension where he's
like no no i'm one of you i'm a ravager
i'm wondering one why he feels that need
to defend and how that all works out but
two we then get a very important moment
where our new gamora appears and she
looks awesome her hair is different
she's got this warrior stance now when
we met her in guardians one she was
obviously a warrior she's been a badass
in all the films but her body language
and her physicality and a lot of those
elements already lend themselves to
being a different gamora i'm fascinated
because this is the first time i think
that we've had a multiversal impact like
this where a character from another
multiverse is now in our multiverse
gamora is gone our gamora is not with us
we have a new one and we're seeing the
impact of having a different version of
a character be a fish out of water with
the character we've known and loved this
is a very sad messed up 50 first dates
with superheroes uh we're gonna see how
it plays out but it was really great to
see gamora back and i'm really excited
to see what zoe does portraying this
character completely differently i do
think nebula is going to be a little bit
different in this film we didn't get to
see a lot of it but we did see her on
stage discussing it as well as this
really beautiful sequence where they're
all skydiving effectively through space
space diving i don't know if that's a
term but they're all wearing these
different colored suits and it's this
beautiful cosmic landscape that is
stunning and these spiraling colors and
it's james gunn it's stunning but you
hear to break the beauty quill talking
to gamora and trying to basically
convince her things are okay and win her
back and like trying to court her all
over again and they land and she calls
him quinn and that obviously is a slight
bit of comedy but it's such sad comedy
it's a beautiful bittersweet i'll keep
using that because that's how i felt it
is funny but it's that huh
like it's that sad laugh that you get
when things go wrong and then the joke
is the one-two punch of good humor of
then you realize that everyone's been
able to hear it and they've all just
been wanting it to stop so it does have
moments of humor but they're a lot more
tinged in sadness if you thought
guardians 2 was sad which i did daddy
issues lots of crying it is about as
further into sadness as guardians 1 to
guardians 2 and guardians 1 has plenty
of sad so this looks brutal now i've got
some theories and they are
mcu spanning i think high evolutionary
who's introduced here
is responsible for rocket raccoon it's
very strongly implied in the trailer i'm
not the first one to think so but it
seems like someone is reaching into baby
rocket's cage and pulling him out i
think that's going to be the high
evolutionary and i think they are going
to be seeking revenge for their friend
rocket there's a line in the trailer
where he basically someone asks off
screen
what happened to rocket and quill says
he doesn't talk about it i think we're
going to see that with high evolutionary
now my theory in conjunction with the
high evolutionary made rocket theory is
that he also might have made the
sovereign his success might be adam
warlock and his moderate success or some
might perceive failure might be rocket
raccoon now rocket has been described as
the saddest creature in the galaxy by
james gunn before and again at this
panel i think this movie is going to be
diving into the origins of rocket i
think it's going to be tragic i think
it's going to be so sad that the
guardians risk everything to get revenge
on a character that basically evolves
people a character who manipulates
reality itself to change how things
evolve and then he came out we had the
high evolutionary come out of the room
and do a long walk and he said a few
lines of like you people disgust me this
is why we have to evolve you like some
fun villain stuff but that was about all
the levity we got was having some
villainy in that room to counteract a
very very sad audience in a very sad
cast and and i don't think that's a bad
thing i think this trilogy is going to
end empire not in return of the jedi i
think that high evolutionary is going to
succeed in a lot of ways and i think
adam warlock is going to be our hero
because he's going to be conflicted i
think we're going to find out that he
maybe this is a theory has been a
creature created by the very thing
they're hunting is that gonna cause some
conflict like does maybe he start as an
enemy does maybe he believe in the high
evolutionary at first and fight the
guardians of the galaxy or does he have
the frankenstein thing where he he
doesn't like his creator there's a lot
of interesting elements you can do with
adam warlock fantastic character by the
way check out jim starlin's out of
morlock stuff also will poulter looks
incredible will poulter as adam warlock
it's a very quick moment in the trailer
but he looks amazing now i do think and
one thing i want to stress is this does
feel like the movie that james gunn has
always wanted to make uh marvel's done
an incredible job making the movie james
gunn has built like you watch guardians
one i would argue guardians one
influenced the entire mcu going more
cosmic because of its success we'll
never know for sure but i feel like that
steered the ship in a different way i
think this is the best way to get the
adam warlock that was teased back in
guardians 2 we saw the cocoon i heard
even that there was reference to moments
with adam warlock hopefully from the
first movie and definitely rocket
raccoon you go back to guardians 1 they
talk about rocket raccoon being
something that is is manipulated and
created i think this has been the movie
that was going to end the trilogy from
the beginning i think it's really
beautiful that marvel has been like hey
make that film because this looks like
something we haven't seen before the
atmosphere in the trailer the scope the
epic it's already a space epic this
looks even bigger than anything we've
seen i don't know if high evolutionary
is going to continue into the mcu but i
will say that this feels like a great
way to introduce pure malice we're
getting kang the conqueror pure malice
we're getting dr doom known for being a
dictator fascist monster i love the idea
that high evolutionary kicks off this
insane oh my god these villains are
awful kick and what better way to do
that than by manipulating a baby raccoon
it's gonna be a great movie i'm really
excited and i'm so honored to have been
in that room we all got to cathartically
collectively cry for our guardians of
the galaxy including the cast themselves
this was wonderful i can't wait for it
to come out thank you for watching i
appreciate each and every one of you if
you guys want to hear more about other
moments in hall h you want to hear more
about some theories leave a comment let
me know what you want to hear about you
guys are the co-hosts of koi's comic
corner greg and john not here i'm
running the stage greg's right
physically he's just not here he's just
he's left but he's off camera so the
giggles are on camera i appreciate you
all very much go hug your moms i love
you bye
[Music]